no it is like a milky sand we are gonna  be with you Monday through Friday to  just jump it up have some hygiene yeah  it's gonna be like a talk right become  the other adjectives as we go along type  of show deodorant is a shower if you  just put it all over your body that's  yeah we also want to include you guys  and see what you like the best and what  we should be doing just overall become a  little fans I miss you I miss you this  is witchcraft  I'll be back every Monday through Friday  right here doing stuff that makes us and  you uncomfortable I don't know what all  of this is true and more as we learn as  we go on this might get dot dot every  day something new  [Music]